now
we have this guy joe biden who's
president of the united states and he's
been busy with a lot of different things
uh just the other day he nominated
catanji brown jackson
to be the next supreme court justice as
you know he decided that he would choose
a black woman in the name of diversity
oddly didn't go with a native american
or a trans lesbian or an asian woman or
something black woman got to be a black
woman so while this is all going on
biden gave a little speech and he got a
little crossed up at the end of it i
this is a little heavy-handed but ah i'm
having fun let me pull this out for you
there you go
you got it but okay
say presidents can't do much
thank you
presidents can't do much
i mean putin is sitting in a room
laughing right now he is he is drinking
vodka and laughing but okay
i get it it was a little heavy-handed
dave you're right people uh so now
here's jen saki she is the white house
press secretary as you know i'm not a
fan of jen saki she cannot say anything
true
here she is explaining how the biden
administration is actually succeeding
with our policy related to russia and
sanctions there's a report in the new
york times that you guys kept asking
china to help you stop russia from
invading ukraine
and they didn't so
what have you guys done
throughout this slow-moving russian
crisis
that has worked
in what capacity well the president
talked to putin he talked to the g7 he
threatened sanctions he put sanctions in
place
now he says the sanctions are going to
take 30 days
or about a month do you guys think the
people in ukraine have about a month
well peter let me just take a step back
and explain to everyone how diplomacy
works and how our approach from the
united states has worked
what the president has done is he has
built a global coalition uh to stand up
in the face of president putin and
president putin's aggression and
invasion of ukraine what he has done is
he has rallied the world our eu european
partners even at cost to them in some
capacities to put in place uh
significant sanctions historic sanctions
that would have a a a enormous impact on
the russian financial sector
dave
breathe deep because as she says that
with a straight face that we've put
enormous sanctions powerful sanctions
these are deep sanctions these are
sanctions that'll do a lot well here's
deputy national security adviser delete
singh talking about those sanctions
to be clear our sanctions are not
designed to cause any disruption to the
current flow of energy from russia to
the world
i couldn't have just did i just maybe i
didn't hear that right could we get that
one one more time because she said i
thought he was very clear that we're
doing a lot with sanctions and we're
going to stop these people because
they're bad people to be clear our
sanctions are not designed to cause any
disruption to the current flow of energy
from russia to the world
do you realize how bananas that is
sanctions what you do with sanctions is
sanctions are designed so that you don't
have to go to war so that you don't have
to bomb people so let's say you want
another country to do something let's
forget what it is we don't have to make
this about russia ukraine anything else
you just have some leverage over a
country you want them to do something
right you're the good guys they're the
bad guys you want them to do something
but you say i don't want to bomb these
people and cause all of that damage and
death and all that so you use sanctions
these are these are ways of turning the
levers of economics so that the country
will hopefully do what it is that you
would like
so that's what you do with sanctions but
we are telling them we are quite
literally
telling russia that the sanctions we're
putting in are not going to affect your
energy
and not going to affect the export of
your energy and the oil and all of that
stuff
this is a problem so what she says there
what sake
says in essence is all nonsense well
we've put together a big group of people
and we're all going to do a lot of stuff
and you know in about a month a whole
bunch of stuff is going to happen and
peter ducey at fox news who i often give
a lot of credit to i give him more
credit because he even says do the
people of ukraine have a month do you
think zelensky out there right now with
a rag tag bunch of people who are being
handed weapons as
his citizens are fleeing to get to the
borders and poland's trying to figure
out how many people they can take and
all of this stuff do you think they have
a month while we're
putting in sanctions that actually won't
do much of anything that would be the
equivalent of trying to punish your kid
and saying you know what you you really
did bad you did that bad thing and we're
going to put you up in your bedroom and
you know yeah there are your ps5s up
there and you're going to get unlimited
soda and pizza and we've got a hooker in
there too and some cocaine have fun at
it you know go for it
i'm not a parent yet so that seemed like
what apparently do i'm working on it um
these people are just absolutely
ridiculous